[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the first episode
of the harry potter story the one that
hooked us
the philosophers or sorcerers stone
now as an introduction to a new series
it doesn't get much better than the
philosopher's stone
by the time you're just a few short
chapters in you're introduced to a
magical world with endless possibilities
a world full of magic wands witches
wizards
and flying broomsticks as a child it was
the best thing i had ever witnessed
the premise of the philosopher's stone
saranswell the philosopher's stone
a stone created by french alchemist
nicholas flamel
with a breadth of powerful capabilities
the ancient study of alchemy
is concerned with making the
philosopher's stone a legendary
substance with astonishing powers
the stone will transform any metal into
pure gold it also produces
the elixir of life which will make the
drinker immortal
okay okay so it's a powerful stone but
how
exactly does it fit into the plot of
harry potter here's the thing
lord voldemort aka tom riddle the
primary antagonist of the harry potter
story
always sought one thing immortality he
wanted to live forever
and that's part of the reason that he
went to such great lengths to create his
horcruxes
risking everything so that he wouldn't
have to suffer as a consequence of his
own mortality
voldemort wanted to evade death at any
cost as he felt that it was a fate and
befitting of a man
of his level of power he despised his
mother for dying and abandoning him
it was a fate reserve for the weak and
unambitious
needless to say voldemort knew about the
stone and wanted it desperately
flamel the stone's creator eventually
entrusted its ownership to hogwarts
headmaster
albus dumbledore as he knew that
dumbledore would be able to protect it
much better than for mel himself
dumbledore took the task of protecting
the stone
very seriously putting numerous safety
measures in place
to ensure the stone was properly
protected
however i want to explore a few things
in this video
number one is were the obstacles enough
if the stone was reached by trio of
first years then how could it have been
considered even
remotely enough to hold off voldemort
and
number two did dumbledore in fact want
harry to reach the stone
did he want him to reach voldemort let's
look further
in total there were eight obstacles in
the way of the stone with varying
difficulties
some were almost pointless and others
had some degree of difficulty
obstacle number one was hardly an
obstacle at all a locked door
however i'm pretty sure this one was
just put in place to stop an unfortunate
student
from wandering in to the next obstacle
fluffy
fluffy was obstacle number two a giant
three-headed dog
that guarded a trapdoor that would serve
as an entryway to the remaining
challenges protecting the stone
despite fluffy's immense size and
unquestionable ability to
kill i don't think that anyone thought
that he would truly hold voldemort off
what they may have thought however is
that the inevitable clash between fluffy
and voldemort
would have at least attracted some
attention enough attention to alert
dumbledore and the other professors
obstacle number three was devil's snare
a magical plant that constricts and
strangles anything that happens to fall
into it
the devil's snare was waiting at the
bottom of the trap door next to fluffy
which meant that as soon as they had
passed fluffy they were hit with another
challenge
here's the thing devil's snare would be
a great protective measure
if only it wasn't counted with a spell
taught in first
year apology probably not a great
defense against
oh one of the most powerful dark wizards
of all time
obstacle number four was a room filled
with flying keys one of which was the
correct key to open the door to obstacle
number five
however not only were there tons of
flying keys there was also a broom
available for the taking
the moment the contact was made with the
broom the keys began flying around
erratically making it supremely
difficult to try and capture the correct
key this obstacle is good in theory
however i do wonder why a broom would be
provided at all
surely if the goal is protecting the
stone by any means
then it doesn't make any kind of sense
to make the goal of reaching the stone
any more achievable also i can't help
but think that there could have simply
been an alternate spell used on the door
avoiding the hassle of capturing a key
altogether obstacle number five was the
giant chess set
a magical obstacle put in place that
required checkmating the enemy king to
advance further
this obstacle is not bad particularly as
if you weren't a chess pro you'd run
into a considerable level of difficulty
the trio advanced through the challenge
because of ron but it did divide the
group
which was perhaps the intention of this
challenge separating people from any aid
that they may have had
thus far as far as we can tell voldemort
tom riddle
was basically a prodigy so i'm fairly
certain that winning the game of chess
would have been a breeze for him
obstacle number six was the troll room
a room with a big old troll however
fortunately for the trio
the troll was already unconscious a
disgusting smell filled their nostrils
making both of them pull their robes up
over their noses eyes watering they saw
flat on the floor in front of them a
troll even larger than the one they had
tackled
out cold with a bloody lump on its head
again this kind of challenge may have
been difficult
for a regular witch or wizard and
certainly for a regular group of first
years
but voldemort come on obstacle number
six was the potion room
one of the better obstacles protecting
the stone the room contained
seven unlabeled potions and tested the
intruder's logic
along with the seven unlabeled potions
was a riddle written on a piece of paper
the potions themselves also trapped the
intruder between black and purple flames
in order to correctly pass the flames
the intruder would have to solve the
riddle
this obstacle was particularly efficient
at its ability to divide
groups as there was only enough potion
to allow one individual
through the complexity of this
particular obstacle
made it in my opinion the only real
obstacle
so far harry was able to get through
with the intellect of hermione
however as i mentioned earlier voldemort
was prodigious himself
obstacle number eight was the mirror of
erised with the exception of the
potion's obstacle
the mirror of era said was in my opinion
the only real protection of the stone
in case you've forgotten how the mirror
of aerosaid works it's a magical mirror
that shows us the deepest most desperate
desires
of our hearts the mirror was
dumbledore's primary contribution to the
stone's protection
i'll let dumbledore explain his thinking
here only a person who wanted to find
the stone
find it but not use it would be able to
get it
that is one of my more brilliant ideas
and between you and me
that is saying something as dumbledore
mentioned above
when you arrived at the mirror obstacle
the only way to get the stone would be
to see yourself possessing it
in the mirror this is where things would
get tricky for voldemort
anyone that wanted to use the stone for
their own purposes
simply couldn't have it however here's
why i still don't think it was well
protected
dumbledore knew that harry would reach
the stone dumbledore wasn't an oblivious
man
he knew all about harry the prophecy and
voldemort
he knew that harry would be the one to
defeat him and he knew that the pair
were destined to meet at some point or
another
from the very beginning of the first
book harry is given clues regarding the
stone's existence
while in diagon alley with hagrid hagrid
decides to bring harry with him to
gringotts and collect the stone
when he very well could have just done
that by himself any other time
why would he have combined shopping with
harry with such an important task
if not to somehow subtly alert harry to
the stone's existence
was it hagrid's ignorance or was it
perhaps perhaps
instruction from dumbledore with the
existence of the stone planted in
harry's mind he was bound to be curious
what was this mysterious object they
picked up from the vault and why
just after retrieving the stone with
hagrid was the vault targeted by thieves
dumbledore was no fool he knew that
harry's curiosity was going to get the
better of him
and that is why i think that he planned
for voldemort and harry's encounter
to test the bounds of the prophecy and
just how linked the pair really were
the obstacles put in place to prevent
voldemort from retrieving the stone
were really just obstacles for harry
tests that would determine whether or
not harry really was
the boy who lived and the boy that was
destined to defeat voldemort
they were formalities a way of giving
the outward appearance of protecting the
stone
while planning on having harry reach the
stone all along knowing that hagrid
would always look after harry's best
interest
dumbledore kept hagrid in the dark
mostly but instructed him to subtly
mention the existence of the stone
without ever explaining why dumbledore's
intentions weren't bad
but they weren't good either he
essentially put all of the premises in
place
for harry to face the dark lord himself
and watched on eagerly
and in secret as harry progressed
through each trial with his friends
when harry finally reached the chamber
and was faced with voldemort
dumbledore's attention peaked as this
was the moment that would determine
whether or not harry was the real deal
the events that transpired in that
chamber
were what would shape harry's life for
the remainder of his time at hogwarts
as once dumbledore realized what and who
harry was
he subtly influenced the course of his
life so that the prophecy could be
fulfilled
and voldemort could be defeated and
that's it for this video
in closing i just want to mention that
all of the above mentioned
about dumbledore's behavior is purely a
theory i love dumbledore's character and
are more than willing to give him the
benefit of the doubt
but i thought it was at least some food
for thought what do you guys think
was dumbledore planning for harry and
voldemort to meet all along
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
strange how nearsighted being invisible
can make you
[Music]
you